لابد ان يكون بدايه الطريق واضحه ونهايه
الطريق ايضا واضحه بل لكي نتخذ الخطوه
الاولى لابد ان نعرف اين نتجه في هذه
[موسيقى]
المسيره ازمه الحاليه في
غزه
هي دليل قاطع على ان طالما هناك احتلال
طالما هناك ظلم لشعب لابد ان يكون هناك رد
فعل ورد الفعل يؤدي الى رد فعل من الطرف
الاخر ونستمر في حلقه من العنف والعنف
المضاد على مدى اكثر من 70 عاما الخروج من
هذه الازمه
يتطلب شيء واحد ومنطقي وهو ان ناخذ في
اعتبار طموحات ومصالح
كافه اطراف بمعنى الشعب الفلسطيني يريد
الحصول او ممارسه حقه في دوله ذات سياده
والجانب الاسرائيلي حسب ما يعلن يريد
تامين نفسه امنيه ومن ثم لنخرج من الازمه
الحاليه بكافه
جوانبها علينا تاكيد على الهدف
النهائي واتخاذ خطوات عمليه لنصل الى هذا
الهدف بمعنى التاكيد اولا على الالتزام ب
الحق الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وحدود اسرائيل في
حدود
67 ووفق لقرار 22 مجلس الامن وايضا وفقا
للمبادره العربيه من قمه بيروت عام 2002
في هذا السياق يمكن النظر في خطوات
عمليه لان العمليه دي تقع في خريطه الطريق
لا ننسى اننا بدانا وفشلنا في عمليات سلام
متعدده في الماضي وانتهى الوضع الى
استيطان اسرائيلي متوسع في الضفه وحتى كان
ايضا قبل ذلك في غاز اذا مطلوب كخطوه اولى
تديد الهدف وتاكيده مطلوب التزام اقليمي
ودولي بهذه بهذا الهدف بعد ذلك يجب ان نظر
الى خطوات متوسطه فيما بين وف طق النار
كخطوه اولى ما بين التبادل المحتجزين
والاسر المساله ليست فقط الاسر
الاسرائيليين انما ايضا المحتجزين
الفلسطينيين وفيما بين هداره العلاقه
الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه واقصد هذه الصياغه
مستقبلا ان المساله ليست قطاع غزه مستقله
عن الضف انما العلاقه الفلسطينيه
الاسرائيليه باكملها واعاده بناء غزه
واعاده تمكين المواطنين من العوده اليها
وخطوات عمليه
ل نحو انشاء دوله فلسطينيه بجوار الدوله
الاسرائيليه بمعنى اخر وكرر مره اخرى لابد
ان يكون بدايه الطريق واضحه و الطريق ايضا
واضح بل لكي نتخذ الخطوه الاولى لابد نعرف
اين نتجه في هذه
[موسيقى]
المسيره